"The Walking Dead" is a fan favorite show, and
once the most watched cable television series.
Because of the series' longevity, viewers got to
watch as many characters aged before their eyes.
And after the show’s time jump in Season 9,
many younger characters were completely recast
to reflect their drastic age changes, resulting
in some roles that have had multiple actors
Judith Grimes was born during "The Walking Dead"
Season 3, when Maggie performed an emergency
delivery, while the prison in which the survivors
were staying became overrun with zombies.
Judith's mother Lori died in childbirth,
and Lori's husband Rick raised Judith
alongside his son, Carl. A total of
18 actors — many of them twin infants
or babies — have played the character on
the show since Judith's first appearance.
Twins Chloe and Sophia Garcia-Frizzi played Judith
as a toddler as she aged from Seasons 6 to 8,
with Kinsley Isla Dillon taking over the
role as a 6-year-old Judith in Season 8.
Following Rick's disappearance in Season 9,
the story experienced a six-year time jump,
in which Judith aged, necessitating
the role's recasting. Cailey Fleming
then took over the part and will
continue to play Judith in Season 11.
Fleming is no stranger to
fans of genre TV and film.
She played a young Rey in the last
two "Star Wars" movies — "The Force
Awakens" and "The Rise of Skywalker" — and
she recently played young Sylvie on "Loki."
Fleming's introduction as Judith is one
of the most memorable in the series.
Aged by several years, Judith emerged
from the woods holding Rick's gun,
carrying Michonne's katana,
and wearing Carl's hat.
Since her big brother Carl's
death and Rick's disappearance,
Judith has been raised by Michonne
and her half-brother, R.J.,
and she's proven herself as capable of killing
zombies as her more experienced family members.
Viewers first met 10-year-old Henry in Season
7. A member of The Kingdom, Henry was taken care
of by his older brother Benjamin, who was
murdered by a Savior during a supply run.
On a mission for revenge, Henry insisted on
joining Carol in the fight against the Saviors,
proving himself a valuable member in
the battle against Negan. Henry, who was
adopted by Ezekiel and Carol during the Season
9 time jump, was also known as "Prince Henry."
Initially portrayed by Macsen Lintz, Henry became
a 17-year-old young man seemingly overnight,
and Matt Lintz took over the
role from his younger brother.
The Lintz family has a long history
with "The Walking Dead." Their sister,
Madison Lintz, played Carol's
daughter, Sophia, in Seasons 1 and 2.
The older Henry moved to the Hilltop
Colony, became a blacksmith's apprentice,
and fell in love with Lydia, a former
Whisperer whose mother, Alpha, disowned
her after she formed a bond with Daryl Dixon and
others from the communities — including Henry.
Alpha captured and killed Henry by
decapitation as a message to her
daughter and the others, marking the end
of the Lintzes’ appearances on the show.
Few "Walking Dead" characters have been as beloved
as Glenn Rhee, whose death at the hands of Negan
in Season 6 hit fans hard, and served a huge blow
to the show when fans found the scene outrageous.
Fortunately, the character has lived
on through his son with wife Maggie.
Outside of ultrasound images, Hershel
Rhee made his first appearance on the
show in Season 9 as a baby, only to age
six years after Rick's supposed death.
“He’s just perfect. He really is.”
Maggie and Hershel left Hilltop for Georgie's
group so they wouldn't be near Negan,
but they're expected to play a large
part in the upcoming final season.
During his time on the show, young Hershel
has been portrayed by three actors,
including Peyton Lockridge in Season 9 and
the most recent actor, Kien Michael Spiller.
The young boy wears a hat reminiscent
of Glenn's from Season 1 and 2,
and he seems to have a gentle
nature, just like his grandfather.
Only time will tell what the future holds for the
son of one of the show's most popular couples.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more LOOPER videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.